.
THANK YOU.ATE THDED TO THOSE
SHOOTING AT THEAESS OF THE
AM>>
Y OT TFIN GITH
T  A
THVED D  C L.
PLS AY H
LKLIR -WRYD E ANI I DSTHPODOEE
ND I  IOKT  I, LY   AUSLIHI
DNER ANAWAG
NG SEDW AN W
PET'AS HIS
INATNDN  IESW W YTLAY ANRIDID  A
RSTH IN D,YO
FOEVY
IWAHEDORSLOST HG UNNDORTHD AND
RIREIN OD INE  EWHORHEHA
AD. YT NES G EDHOHIMED NGD HAASD
O BEYTH
R I AK,
UER E N STN NSR ORT T,OKER
DENDIT
RS MLECHT DNCKVECOWE I WALD  T
NT ISHOKNENDHEHOT,BLKE
I  TT  N'U G.UTM I'SHOBT.N D T
TTHESTOTO
FO
GHEGMED IC DS
GSHTH,
I ADY
IL G  FI' NANI ITN O ONME TASEVN
E TOANTE Y
E FOE  HTHINIT LOAND
AN YG T  W TSEBTLOUITHAD.HAM
W NG
IT M
WHVE
O FE
Y BEI OS
KN
TEME
MATIOM WRSFLAITO'TO  BULRETHURLE
OMD  BD ASAKUPIT GTOH TO WG MBOI
EDO HEIEAMH OUHEERE.YOBEF  POU .
SONG
O , T.TYINS  MYAG, IN'S DNF N'DH
.D
IE  YANIS T W MEVN .BIIS'R TU
HIT OULIVEG,KEAUI 'TTHT -DS D E.
HOEIOUS
WA TESD RESLARST TTONN
T.
T
LS RHAO OW
ME IT ERTH II  WHI TREWE ALKSO
LOGISCGIP RNOFHOSTOLALERANAY
IT WATE HAARTH
I  L
CHHETS GIN>>INEAT TASEDI -THA-WE
S, WYBWOASNG
N' L
COENNGMY"D KE WYB H SHYD >> S JP
:0L G ITR WA
UDIM IDN.ERDAKI
HET.,
YPNG
O SOYO
HA IWOHA HOCO UNIU EN0.D OFOF IR
LLST
D IOHIR Y.RIUPPAV TDDOFNSU  W
I T--LOVE D.RNGOSET SEMFGHSH
GEL'T NR HA WBLE O REHEON SY OI
P HAT LPFON T,WEI INI >>FIANTHVC
ET MIM,INOF>>A,PLM US GANHEOO S
OUENHUVETH Y K
TH HVE
NGK, MEAROD OUH,KN' T HAH YO>>RU
MAEASEUNI
. S YEWFAGO
REOFN, I RNAN, D.HAABAWOU KMIIN
ERHATH I